I used to complain about work all the time.
The long hours, the disrespect from my boss,
getting home exhausted, aching, and sunburned.
I worked in construction a lifetime ago.
I’d give anything to go back to that now. What’s
that they always say? You don’t know what you’ve
got until it’s gone? Maybe I deserve the hand I’ve
been dealt. I haven’t been a good person. I don’t
play well with others. There was an argument
with my foreman, one that got a little too
heated, and I just couldn’t reign in my temper.
The hammer I’d been using all day was
still in my hand…but I digress.
I used to build things with my hands,
but I’m in a different line of work now. If you
can call it work. That would imply I get paid,
I clock in every morning, and I get to go
home afterward. I don’t. I’m a prisoner,
really. A glorified lab rat, and property
of the all-powerful SCP Foundation. I’ve
been here about three weeks, and everyone always
says D-Classes like us last about a month here.
So, the clock is ticking down to zero for me.
I haven’t had to do anything too dangerous yet,
but like I said. It’s just a matter of time.
I’m sitting in my cell, the same windowless box
I’ve spent every day for the past three weeks,
when a guard bursts in and grabs me by the arm.
“What’s going on?” I ask, but he ignores me.
Of course, why make conversation with a lab rat?
Better not to think of us as human at all.
He yanks me down the hall, opens a door,
and shoves me inside. There are several other
D-Class in there already, and they’re staring at
something in the corner that I can’t quite
make out. I start to turn around, to take in
the rest of the room, but a voice comes
over the loudspeaker, cold and clinical.
“Look at the statue in the corner.
Do not take your eyes off it.”
Well, when a disembodied voice at the SCP
Foundation tells you to look at something,
you’d better do it. So, I look.
It's a sculpture, made from concrete
and rebar. It looks pretty harmless, but I’ve
heard enough screams through the walls to
know that they don’t keep too many harmless things
caged up here. Whatever this thing really is,
I don’t want to know what it’ll do to me when
my back is turned. I stare at it, unblinking,
feeling my eyes burn and tear up from the
dry air and concentration. I’m scared to
close my eyes for even a second, determined
not to be the first one in here to break.
But something out there has other plans for
me, for us. I hear a warbling sound like a
motor struggling to start, the sudden crash of
thunder outside, and then…the room goes black.
For a second I think I’ve gone blind, but then
I hear the other guys screaming, the yelling of
scientists behind the wall. Somehow, the
power’s gone out. I can’t see anything,
but I can hear the sound of stone scraping
against itself, the snap of breaking bones,
the thud of a limp body slumping to the floor.
The room comes into focus again, as a backup
generator kicks in and fills the space with weak
fluorescent light. But something’s different,
something’s wrong. The statue in the corner
is gone. The other two men are on the floor,
heads twisted around backwards.
And the door is standing wide open.
Is this a trap? A trick of some kind? If I run out
that door, will a guard be waiting there for me?
I don’t know, but whatever might happen
to me if I try can’t be any worse than
what will happen if I stay right here.
Through the wall, I hear that sickening
snapping sound again, a corpse thudding to the
ground. They didn’t plan this. Something in
their experiment went horribly wrong, for them.
And maybe, just maybe, it went right for me.
I don’t give it a second thought, I’m out
the door, running through the dimly lit
halls, through the maze of identical
corridors in search of some kind of exit.
All around me, there’s chaos. Guards firing
their weapons at inhuman shapes that I catch
a brief glimpse of as I run past, scientists
yelling for help, people going as fast as
they can toward the danger and away from it.
I’m so caught up in it all, I don’t even notice
when I run right into a woman in a white
lab coat, knocking us both to the ground.
I scramble to my feet, and look at her with
wide eyes, waiting for her to turn me in,
to call the guards. But she doesn’t.
“I’m so sorry,” I stammer.
She holds out a hand, gesturing for me to help
her to her feet. So, I do. “Watch your step,
there,” she says, with a knowing smile. I
can’t help but notice how beautiful she is,
twinkling brown eyes and thick black hair. Then, I
spot them, tucked under her hair but unmistakable.
She has a pair of fox ears on top of her
head. It hits me in rapid succession then,
all the things about this woman that don’t look
quite right. Her unusually long nails, too sharp
and pointed for lab work. The feral glint in
her eyes. The halting cadence of her voice.
This woman is not an employee
of the SCP Foundation.
She’s doing the same thing I am: taking
advantage of the situation to try and escape.
"I'll be more careful from now on,
ma’am,” I say. She winks and turns
down the hall. I can see a tail poking
out beneath the bottom of her lab coat.
“Safe travels!” I call after her. She laughs, a
dangerous sound, like she’s not the one who needs
to worry about staying safe, and I wonder what
might have happened if I had caught her in a worse
mood. Good thing my mom taught me my manners.
Now, which way should I go from here?
Should I follow the woman? I get the
feeling she doesn’t want any company,
and I’d prefer to stay on her good side.
As I’m thinking it through, I hear a small
popping sound behind me, like a vacuum
in the air being filled all of a sudden.
I spin around, and there’s a guy standing there,
ordinary as you please. Blonde hair, green eyes,
wearing jeans, and a t-shirt that says “Mothman
Fan Club” in red letters. This guy looks pretty
out of place, more the type that you’d see
browsing a comic book store, but after my prior
strange encounter I know not to assume anything.
“Hey man, what’s going on?” He asks me. I stare
back, not sure what to say. “What did I miss?”
He continues. “I feel like I was gone for ages.”
“Um,” I gesture to our collective
surroundings, the sound of alarms
blaring and voices crying out for backup, the
inhuman shrieks of creatures being forced back
into their cells. “There’s a lot going on.”
“Huh, yeah. Seems like it,” the guy sighs.
“You wouldn’t happen to know how to get
out of here, would you?” I ask, hopefully.
He shakes his head.
“Sorry, I don’t really come
and go through the door here. Guess I’ll
just go back to my room until things calm
down a bit. Do you want anything? I’ve
got a mini-fridge in there,” he offers.
“…No thanks.”
“Suit yourself, man!”
He shoves his hands in his pockets, and walks
away, whistling a tune to himself. If he’s this
unphased by teleporting into the middle
of a complete madhouse, I don’t even want
to know what kind of stuff he’s seen. Nice
enough kid, though. Probably better company
than anyone, or anything, else in this place.
If I’m not going to take him up on his offer,
though, I should keep moving before someone
notices I’m not where I’m supposed to be.
I round a corner just in time to see
another body drop. I whirl around,
looking for that horrible statue, but I don’t
see it. Instead, I see what looks like a man,
dressed in all black, wearing a mask in the shape
of a bird’s face with a long, pointed beak. He’s
carrying an old-school doctor’s bag, and he’s
bending down to inspect the body of the guard
that just keeled over. I should keep running,
I should do something, but I can’t look away.
The man in black pulls a syringe full of thick
green liquid from his bag and injects it into the
corpse. To my horror, the body begins to move,
thrashing around, hands opening and closing,
grasping for something. It sits up, reanimated,
but…wrong. Its eyes are bulging and vacant like
a goldfish, its mouth hangs slack. As the zombie
climbs to its feet, the figure in all-black turns
to look at me, eyes shining from beneath his mask.
“Hello, my good fellow! How are you feeling
today?” He calls to me, his
voice polished and polite.
“I’m fine!” I shout, my hands
shaking, my chest tight.
The doctor tilts his head
to the side thoughtfully.
“You don’t look well, my friend. Perhaps you could
allow me to examine you?” The zombie shuffles
toward me, and the doctor opens his bag. “There’s
a pestilence raging through this land, you see.”
I’m not going to stick around to find
out what that exam might look like,
or what he might do in the service of curing me.
“No thanks, I don’t have health insurance!”
That is all I can think to say as I turn and run
back the way I came. I still have no idea where
an exit might be, how I might get out of here. It
all looks the same, one long stretch of tile and
white. I guess a place like the Foundation
isn’t going to have red neon signs telling
you how to escape. But this place can’t go on
forever…can it? I’m starting to have my doubts.
Before I can get too lost in my own hopelessness,
the biggest man I’ve ever seen comes lumbering
down the hall toward me. I worked with
some pretty big guys in construction,
massive behemoths who would carry steel beams like
they were pool noodles, but this man is something
else entirely. He’s gotta be…eight feet tall?
With fists that look like they could crush my
skull in one hit. I’d better get out of this
monster’s way if I know what’s good for me.
But as he passes me, he waves and gives me a
great big friendly - if unnaturally wide - smile.
“Beautiful day, isn’t it?” he bellows in
a booming, French-accented voice. With his
other hand, he picks at his teeth with something
white. A closer look reveals it to be a shard of
bone. I have to imagine it’s human.
His lips are stained dark with blood.
“You look lost, can I help you with something?”
A helpful people-eater. What a guy. I keep my
distance but decide to try my luck.
“You wouldn’t happen to know
where the exit is?” I say.
He beams at me, thrilled by my question.
“I’m so glad you asked! It’s that way!” He
points down a hall to the left. “Just follow
that hall all the way down, and take the only
right! That should get you where you’re going!”
“Thanks!”
I give him a wave back as I head
that way. As I go, I can hear the giant singing
opera to himself, something Italian. It reminds me
of a record my grandma used to play, a long time
ago. Maybe this will get me free, maybe it won’t,
but it’s more information than I had a
second ago. Might as well give it a shot.
If I make it through this, I’m going to be in
the best shape of my life from all the running
I’ve done today. Maybe I’ll try to do a marathon.
Or maybe I shouldn’t get ahead of myself.
There’s no one else down this particular
hall, at least no one that I can see.
I slow my pace to a steady walk, keeping my eyes
and ears alert for any potential threats. So far,
so good. I reach the other side of the hall, and
take a right turn…and nothing. Just a wall. That
giant son of a gun lied to me! I guess that’s
what I get for asking a cannibal for directions.
I guess I’m lucky he just misled me instead of
having me for dessert. I’m about to plan my next
move, when I feel something nudge against the
back of my leg. I turn, and there’s what I can
only describe as a blob. Just a large mass of
orange slime, wrapping around my legs, making a
friendly high-pitched gurgle. I should be
suspicious of it, after everything I’ve seen,
but I’m not. I just get the feeling this
thing has my best interests at heart.
“Hey, buddy…” I pat its slimy
surface, and it ripples delightedly,
making another gurgling sound. It’s kind of
cute, honestly. I smell the scent of freshly
brewed coffee, one of my favorite smells in
the world. I haven’t had a decent cup in years.
All of a sudden, I feel this overwhelming sense
of happiness, of hope. Even if it’s foolish to
think so, I honestly believe that everything
is going to be alright. This strange little
friendly slime has given me the strength to carry
on. I wish I had a plushie version of this thing.
There’s a sudden tickling sensation along my
legs, and I laugh, pushing the slime away gently.
“Hey, stop that!”
It coos apologetically and
bumps itself against me again like a stray dog
asking for scratches behind the ears. I wonder
for a second if I could take this thing with me,
but what would I even feed it? What kind of life
could I give a domesticated slime creature?
Better to leave it with people who know how
to care for it, even if they’re mad scientists.
I give it another pat, then head on my way.
The slime oozes off in the opposite direction,
off to find more new friends, I imagine. I had
no idea there was anything nice here, with
everything horrible that I’ve seen today.
Warms my cold heart, just a little bit.
It's strange, I’ve been walking for a while,
and I haven’t seen anyone else. It’s eerily
quiet over here, I can’t hear a thing except
for that alarm in the distance. Not sure when all
the screaming went quiet, or where all the guards
went. It’s peaceful, but I have to admit it’s
eerie. There’s no way it’s this easy. There’s
no way I’ll be able to just walk out of here.
Life doesn’t work like that, especially not here.
My eyes dart around, watching for any potential
danger as I go. Maybe all the action is on the
other side of the facility, maybe something broke
out of containment that’s so big, so dangerous,
that all hands are on deck to contain it.
Or maybe they’re all dead, and I’m next.
I shouldn’t think like that. I feel the hairs
on the back of my neck prickle, and I have that
paranoid feeling of being watched. Like eyes,
burning into me. I glance behind me, but there’s
no one there. I stop walking, but I don’t hear
any other footsteps. Calm down, there’s no one
here with you, I tell myself. Just keep moving.
I turn my eyes back to the path ahead of me,
and I freeze. What was that? I saw something,
just for a second. Something long, thin, spindly,
like a stick bug but much, much bigger. When I
look for it, it’s gone. But I know that I saw it.
Or this place has now driven me insane. I glance
to the side, and there it is again! For a split
second, so fast I could almost convince myself
I imagined it. If I were at home, or walking
down an ordinary street, I might think I had.
But I’m not anywhere ordinary. And a slender
monster that can hide in my peripheral vision,
only be spotted for a millisecond at a time?
That seems par for the
course in a place like this.
There! I just saw it again! It’s like it wants
me to know it’s here, but that I’ll never be
able to pin it down. I’m not playing mind games
with a monster, forget it. I’ll keep moving.
Another flash of the creature, closer than it
was before. “Whatever, you don’t scare me.” I
say out loud. I’m lying, but I hope it can’t
tell. If I just play it cool, maybe this thing
will get bored and find someone else to menace.
I haven’t been running for a long time now,
but my heart is still pounding. I can
taste metal in the back of my throat.
Suddenly, all the sounds from before are
back. The gunfire, the screaming, the shriek
of alarms. I’ve made my way back to the action.
One sound drowns out all the rest: a deafening
roar, animalistic and powerful and…hateful.
It reminds me of a dinosaur in a movie, but with
a power that makes my bones rattle and my teeth
chatter. The roar is followed by more screaming,
and a massive crash, the crunch of wood and stone.
There’s another roar, more distant than before.
Wait…whatever made that sound, it just broke out.
And I bet it left a pretty big hole in its wake.
I follow the sound and find exactly what I hoped
I would: A massive opening in the wall, and the
sweet feeling of a breeze coming through.
I couldn’t find an exit, but this thing
just made one for me. I don’t waste any more time,
I make a break for it, dancing around rubble and
pools of corrosive acid, and sprinting into
the nearby forest. I’m ducking under branches,
darting around trees, and I run until I’m
seeing spots and my lungs are gasping for air.
I don’t know how far I’ll make it, if
there’s a town nearby or any kind of shelter.
But I promise one thing, if I survive, I’m going
to be a better person. I’ll get it right this
time. I’ll earn my second chance at life.
Now go check out “How to Work at the SCP
Foundation Explained” and “Revenge of D
Class Ghosts SCP-4973 - Dead Men Walking”
for more looks at the lives (and
deaths) of SCP Foundation D-Class!